the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay code looks a little bit daunting
but it's not that bad really the only
part of the code that actually does
something is this part right here where
we're trying to do this these three
lines the first being we get an input
from the user that says hold ru we're
converting that to an integer we're
gonna take that number that they gave
you that they gave us divided by 80 I'm
assuming life expectancy is 80 and
multiply by hundred to get the percent
gonna round it to one and then I'm gonna
print you've gone through that much
percent of your life okay
so again we're dealing with user input
which is unpredictable so we're gonna
catch first of all a value error and
that's if the user doesn't enter a
number in that case we're gonna say oops
you must enter a number and then we're
going to also catch the zero division
error which says print divided by trying
to do a division by zero and otherwise
we're how the last except that says
something went very wrong so it looks
like people are getting it right the
question being if the user enters 20
what does the program do okay so we're
giving a string and strings taken in as
input and then trying to convert those
to an integer gives us a value error so
it's going to go through this except
block here and print that which is great
most of you guys are getting that right
and then the next one perfect I tricked
some of you the next one says if the
user enters 0 what does the program do
well what does the program do we're
gonna take in 0 we're gonna do 0 times
100 divided by 80 that's fine it's
always going to be 0 we're gonna round
that to 1 and then we're gonna print
that out so no zero division error no
value error everything went right so
that means it's going to print out this
the first one okay so that's this one
here so the zero division error only
happens when you're trying to divide
something by zero
right in this case we're not the zeros
at the top of the fraction